the coach his wife der - I never got to
see the first one so why are you talking
about the sequel
[Music]
today we're guessing real versus fake
porn titles if my mom is watching this
my knowledge of porn titles is scant
what is porn porn who does he work here
pornography and leaving she's a nice
lady I think I've searched am i addicted
to porn like multiple times in my life
and my mom's not watching yes I've been
preparing for this since I was 13 the
touch of the [ __ ] one of this is like a
spin on a really literary novel from the
American canon I don't know it's lovely
it does have a certain elegance to add a
touch of the [ __ ] this is dumb so I'll
say it's real I'm gonna say you made it
up
I'm gonna say fake - yeah yeah yeah
adventures in your anus I don't know why
but I feel like it's fake here's the
thing I think straight people are still
a little weirded out by but stuff it
implies extensive insertion he's writing
a dissertation
again I'm gonna I'm gonna agree with
Sheridan on this then I'm gonna say this
is fate this like checks all the boxes
for like punny yeah parody exciting I
think it's real my plays real adventures
and Uranus is real and if it's not real
get the licensing done tonight
what white man came home first of all
you like that one like you feel like
this could be a straight part time this
is not a gay porn title we don't do
clever parodies it's like xxx men like
Wolverine gets pounded by XD we're gonna
go away real let's do it that was worse
that was real I've got a nose for this
Forrest hump I think that that's a real
one because that is very literal they
are humping in a forest that should not
be real okay I you think it's real I
think it's real
we're gonna go it's real I'm gonna go
with real that's true point parodies
real P the extra testicle no no nah that
can't be real please don't let it be
real it's like so crazy that it might be
real
no with real that's another like movie
period yeah so I'd say that's yeah I
think it's real humanity know what
happened to the greatness and quality of
titles like Pope made can't hog sausage
galore that affected me it's like a hard
one like a gang bang or like a circle
jerk or something like that the pizza
you would order or a pizza delivery poor
yes say it's real I'm not sure I'm not
sure this is the hard one
no no I feel like it could it could go
either way I'm gonna say fake oh my god
right yeah I want to say we're really
good at guessing porn titles but we're
like just barely above average he kicked
ass yeah we didn't really want been cute
if we had gone like seven
seven for heater six or eight not really
well do they have a problem right
[Music]